on est prêt pour le départ pour la
maraude oui tout à fait et bien c'est
parfait allons-y je t'écoute pour
l'adresse c'est le nom du bénéficiaire
et des secours il est fort mais voilà la
devise de la protection civile
parmi les missions de l'association les
maraudes samu social
objectif sortir les bénéficiaires de la
rue le rôle des bénévoles a mené une
aide matérielle et alimentaires mais
aussi et surtout apporter une aide
psychologique et effectuer un suivi du
bénéficiaire
on discute on parle ça qu'on crée du
lien et ça c'est même parfois presque
plus important que la nourriture était
là depuis combien de temps ici du singe
en trois mois trois semaines du coup a
du coup avant que tu es tu étais où
d'accord l'équipe part à la rencontre
des bénéficiaires dans la rue des
personnes qui ont demandé une aide ou
des personnes croisées au fil de la
soirée
elle leur procure kits d'hygiène
couverture café ou encore repas chauds
et font remonter leurs besoins ce qui
est important dans les maraudes c'est la
circulation d'informations c'est pas
juste d'aller donner un café mais c'est
que ses informations remontent au niveau
de la direction départementale de la
cohésion sociale et de l'ensemble des
services pour pouvoir trouver les
solutions pérennes à ces personnes ce
que j'ai noté par rapport à tes besoins
de couverture et où je vais rappeler la
règle pour la prochaine maraude je vais
demander ce qui t'amène de quelque chose
un seul mot d'ordre adaptation les
bénévoles doivent répondre aux demandes
qui arrive la régulation reste en
contact avec l'équipe du début à la fin
de la maraude
quand on part on sait l'endroit on sait
le ou les personnes mais on sait pas
forcément quand la personne à appeler
et on ne sait pas forcément ce qu elle
va avoir besoin en terme de nourriture
en terme de deux kits d'hygiène
là on devait faire une marotte ce
produit là il ya une mission qui tombe
on a bien fait de rappeler la réguler
donc on y va on va voir ce que l'on va
trouver en 2019 les maraudes de la
protection civile avait permis de
rencontrer près de 200 personnes une
aide précieuse pour ces personnes sans
domicile fixe tant mieux que ça existe
car beaucoup de beaucoup de monde qui
sont encore dehors c'est de la nuit il
ya pas mal il ya pas beaucoup de monde
il ya plutôt des fous tu passes on les
connaît pas trop c'est dangereux quoi
embarras peu quand on vous voit le seul
réconfort c'est très difficile surtout
en ce moment avec le confinement est au
bordel là c'est vraiment difficile
franchement moi je suis heureux qu'ils
aient vraiment que sont l'or le premier
confinement c'était dur parce que ils
étaient pas il n'était pas là ils
n'étaient pas ceux des conflits nés une
maraude et organisés chaque semaine un
nombre qui pourrait s'intensifier sur la
période hivernale